uh
all right
uh
oh
foreign
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
house
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
do
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
this is
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
oh
thank you
[Music]
thank you
oh
thank you
uh
[Applause]
hey
oh my gosh
[Applause]
right here
yes
foreign
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this one
thank you
directly
what's up
i just realized
i think
oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
foreign
thank you
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
so
right
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
um
so
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay
to the graduates of the class of 2020
and the members of the class of 2021
and their parents families
and friends here and online
welcome back to yale
today
we gather two years after you earned
your degrees to recognize your
extraordinary accomplishments
you made sacrifices
you overcame adversity
you persevered
this ceremony delayed by historical
global disruption is all the more
meaningful and joyous because of your
hard work
and commitment to the common good
we salute your efforts your diligence
your intellect
and your resilience
we also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported you in these
endeavors
your families
and friends teachers and other members
of the yale
community in keeping with the tradition
of this occasion
i now call on the university chaplain
to offer an invocation
my heart is so full to look at you
with deep gratitude to the quinnipiac
people for this land on which we stand
my beloved yale family i invite you to
join me in the spirit of prayer
almighty and loving creator
you are the force that lights the stars
the architect of every cell
the source of all truth we look to you
as many expressions of one living
mystery
a mystery that is beyond all telling
in this moment of return and reunion
our hearts beat differently
for all that we have been through
we who share this beautiful but aching
world
we who look at the same sun and the same
moon are a people called to
communal restoration
as students of your handiwork we
gathered at yale from throughout the
earth with exquisite ambitions
and have been blessed at this place of
light and truth with the freedom to let
them grow
our god of all generations
you are the guardian of where we are
going and who we are becoming
we are filled with gratitude for our
families friends teachers and guides
their arms have sheltered us
their shoulders have boosted us
and today their hearts are holding fast
to us
bless us as we seek to reimagine a world
made better by the considerable gifts we
are bringing to it
may we exude an intelligence that is
inspired by justice
guided by tenderness
moved by holiness
and always informed by love
as we continue to greet tomorrow
steady us on solid ground
and together may we become vibrant
living examples of shalom of selam of
shanti
of peace
for this we say
amen
please be seated
graduates of the class of 2020 and the
class of 2021
family members and friends
it's rare for a university president to
have the opportunity to speak formally
with you twice to celebrate your
graduation
looking at all of you now
knowing so many are also with us online
i'm deeply grateful for the chance to do
so
none of us could have predicted when we
first met at your opening assemblies
that the culmination of your bright
college years would coincide
with the onset
of a once in a generation pandemic
you gave up big moments and missed out
on quieter ones
but the challenges posed by the kova 19
pandemic did not define your time at
yale
instead
you are remembered for your compassion
strength
and character
former university president kingman
brewster
once distilled the selection of our
future students as a combination
of looking for those with a zest to
stretch the limits of their talents
and those with an outstanding public
motivation
indeed it was with this outstanding
public motivation
that you accommodated what this moment
in history
asked of you
and it was with this zest to stretch the
limits of your talents
that you asked
how you could serve others
of course commencement weekends are
traditionally occasions for those of us
on the platform to import impart wisdom
as graduates prepare to enter the world
yet
as members of the class of 2020 and 2021
you have flipped this proposition
entirely
you are no ordinary group of graduates
and this
is no ordinary ceremony
so instead we gather today to
commemorate all you taught us
we gather today to applaud your master
class in resilience
and in resolve
class of 2020 you may recall that at
your opening assembly
i concluded my remarks with an
expression of confidence that you would
on your first day of school begin
immediately to seek out what is best
about this place the faculty and staff
and peers
who who will both inspire you and
prepare you
to become the investigators visionaries
and leaders the world so sorely needs
none of us here can hope for a better
world
or even for a more inclusive and
exhilarating learning community at yale
i continued unless we succeed at this
mission
you are in fact what gives us hope
that was six years ago
now
on this ceremonial last day of school
you are still a source of hope
not only because we succeeded at our
mission but also because you succeeded
at yours
not merely because you sought out what
is best about this place when you
arrived
but because
you exemplified it
when you left
in his book the dignity of difference
the late rabbi lord jonathan sachs who
was awarded an honorary degree from yale
describes a subtle yet insightful
distinction between optimism
and hope
optimism he writes is the belief that
things will get better
hope meanwhile
is the faith that together we can make
things better
optimism is a passive virtue
hope and active one
takes no courage to be an optimist rabbi
sax asserts but it takes a great deal of
courage
to have hope
over the last two more years
somber realities around the world have
threatened to diminish our sense of
optimism
but your response to these crises has
provided reason
for hope
with a great deal of courage
you have both believed in a better world
and worked toward it
crisis has catalyzed the progress
it could have hamstrung
i think for instance of margaret kellogg
a 2020 graduate of yale college
and a current member of the saliva
direct team
at the onset of the pandemic
her yale school of public health
colleagues
began work on easy to collect low-cost
high-quality pcr tests
to deploy in communities school
districts and businesses across america
under the leadership of principal
investigator anne wiley millions of
saliva direct tests
have been administered
and the initiative is a blueprint for
how society improves improves access to
affordable infectious disease testing
i think two of margaret's classmate
christina powell and paul gross her
classmates
christina says the inequities made more
visible by the pandemic stoked an
existing ambition
to make the world a fairer place
she has since launched a research
project to examine the haunting rise of
xenophobia
and paul's startup to capture carbon
emissions from semi trucks was founded
during the earliest stages of the
pandemic
neither paul
nor the global crisis he is combating
could wait for the return of impro in
person operations
as i look out on old campus
i see a force for progress
and positive change
leaders who stepped up
at a critical time to help nourish the
hungry
ensure the most vulnerable had access to
essential services
and collect ppe
for frontline workers
i see in you simply the compassion
of the human spirit
members of the class of 2020 and the
class of 2021 you have demonstrated that
the call to serve society inscribed in
our founding document
can endure
and indeed can be ignited
by hardship
you have demonstrated that yale in the
end
is not its oldest books or its newest
laboratories
it is not even the sum of its sweeping
gothic buildings
and their
sharp modernist compliments
you have demonstrated that yale is
simply us
and our best effort to realize our
mission
to improve the world today
and for future
generations
by force of an emergency
we all had to pursue that mission
differently
but we work together
as a community
to pursue it with conviction
you have my deepest appreciation for the
selflessness with which you safeguarded
public health as a student
and for the tenacity
with which you have worked to repair our
world
as a graduate
more than for having your college years
coincide with a pandemic at its worst
you will be remembered
for representing yale
at its best
more than reinvigorating our optimism
you have allowed us the courage
to hope
today we salute your sacrifice
sacrifice that has solidified
your rightful place
in history
and we will celebrate your display
of high moral purpose
that will build the future
we all
so desire
congratulations
it is now my privilege
to call on your deans
to present congratulations from your
schools
mr president
i have the honor to recognize graduates
for the bachelor's degrees in yale
college
for the degree of bachelor of arts
931 in number
and for the degree
of bachelor of science
463 in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
yale college
and approved by the corporation
and they were conferred their degrees by
your official act
by the authority vested in me
it was my honor to confer upon you the
bachelor's degrees in yale college as
designated by the dean and admit you to
all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to
recognize graduates for degrees in the
school of architecture
for the degree master of architecture
137 in number for the degree master of
environmental design five in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation and they were conferred
their degrees by your official act
[Applause]
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the degrees in
architecture and design as designated by
the dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
that's you
yes
[Applause]
mr president
i together with dean kimberly pinder
have the honor to recognize graduates
for degrees in the school of art
for the degree of masters of fine arts
61 in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation
and they were conferred their degrees by
your official
act by the authority vested in me it was
my honor to confer upon you the degree
in art as designated by the dean
and admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr
president i have the honor to recognize
graduates for degrees in the david
geffen school of drama
for the certificate in drama
four in number
for the degree of master of fine arts 62
in number
and for the degree of doctor of fine
arts one in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation and they were conferred
their degrees by your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the certificate
and degrees in drama as designated by
the dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to
recognize graduates for degrees in the
school of music
for the certificate in performance two
in number for the artist diploma three
in number
for the degree master of music 138 and
number for the degree of master of
musical arts
77 in number and for the degree of
doctor of musical arts 12 in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation
and they were conferred their degrees by
your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the certificate
diploma and degrees in music as
designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to
recognize graduates for degrees in the
school of nursing
for the degree of master of science and
nursing
238 in number for the postmaster's
certificate in nursing 2 in number and
for the degree of doctor of nursing
practice 33 in number
[Applause]
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation and they were conferred
their degrees by your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the degrees in
nursing
as designated by the dean and admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to
recognize graduates for degrees in the
school of the environment for the
[Applause]
for the degree of master of forestry 21
in number for the degree of master of
forest science two in number for the
degree of master of environmental
management
196 in number and for the degree of
master of environmental science 38 in
number they were recommended by the
faculty of the school and approved by
the corporation and they were conferred
their degrees by your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the degrees in
forestry and environmental studies as
designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
graduation
[Applause]
mr president
i have the honor to recognize graduates
for degrees in the school of management
for the degree of master of business
administration
758 in number
for the degree of master advanced
management
118 in number
and 40 degree of master and management
studies
120 in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation and they were conferred
their degrees by your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer on you the degrees in
management as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
thank you
mr president
i have the honor to recognize graduates
for degrees in the divinity school
for the degree of master of arts and
religion
142 in number for the degree of master
of divinity 122
in number and for the degree of master
of sacred theology 22 in number they
were recommended by the faculty of the
school and approved by the corporation
and they were conferred their degrees by
your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the degrees in
religion
divinity and theology as designated by
the dean and admit you to all their
rights and responsibilities
mr president i have the honor to
recognize graduate for degrees in the
law school
[Music]
for the degree of master of laws 28 in
number for the degree of masters of
studies in law two in number for the
degree of doctor of the science of law
12 in number and for the degree of juris
doctor
420 in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation and they were conferred
their degree by your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the degrees in
the law school as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to
recognize graduates for degrees in the
graduate school
for the degree of master of advanced
studies 52 in number for the degree of
master of science 109 in number for the
degree of master of arts 95 in number
and for the degree of master of
philosophy
717 in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation and they were conferred
their degrees by your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer upon you the degrees in
the graduate school
as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
mr president i have the honor to
recognize graduates for the degrees in
the school of public health
[Music]
[Applause]
for the degree of master of public
health 207 in number they were
recommended by the faculty of the school
and approved by the corporation and they
will confer their degrees by your
official act
by the authority vested in me it is my
honor to confer upon you the degrees in
public health as designated by the dean
and admit you to all its rights and
responsibilities
congratulations
[Applause]
mr president
i have the honor to recognize
graduates for degrees in the school of
medicine
for the degree of master of medical
science
78 in number
for the certificate in global medicine
one in number
for the degree of master of health
science 35 in number and for the degree
of doctor of medicine 112 in number
they were recommended by the faculty of
the school and approved by the
corporation
and they were conferred their degrees by
your official act
by the authority vested in me it was my
honor to confer the degree in medical
science and the certificate and degrees
in global medicine health science and
medicine as designated by the dean
and admit you to all their rights and
responsibilities
[Applause]
candidates
candidates agradom philosophy doctors
numero kentum octod tray kentum tridekum
te animad ver wheretare vellum
a
[Music]
diplomate
absolutist
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Applause]
please rise
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
like
please be seated
we will now proceed to recognize the
recipients
of the 2020 honorary degrees
the tradition of awarding honorary
degrees at yale began in 1702
honorary degrees are the most
significant recognition
conferred by the yell corporation the
university's board of trustees
to signal pioneering achievement in a
field
or conspicuous and exemplary
contribution
to the common good
honorary degree recipients serve as
examples to all graduates
encouraging you to aspire to excellence
and to value those elements of human
character
that they embody
creativity
curiosity
discipline
integrity
and a passion for public service
those who receive honorary degrees
represent collectively
the aspirations
of this institution
we are pleased to honor in person today
one recipient
and to recognize the honorands who are
not with us today
and i will now call as is customary upon
the provost
to present the 2020 honorary degrees
mr president for the degree of doctor of
engineering and technology
michael i jordan computer scientist
facing an uncertain and complex world
you harness the power of human and
machine learning to solve daunting
problems
by bridging disciplines and following
your curiosity
you have made possible
what was once
only imagined
explorer of new domains champion of big
ideas
in recognition of the doors you have
opened and the networks you have built
we are proud to bestow on you
the doctor of engineering and technology
degree
it is also our pleasure to recognize the
2020
honorary degree recipients
who are not with us today
jim allison
immunologist
jerome allen cohen
legal scholar
christiana figueres
public servant
renee fleming
soprano
herbie hancock musician and composer
ming cho lee
theatrical set designer
cevante pebo evolutionary geneticist
paula vogel playwright and educator
thank you mr provost please rise
[Music]
the lord
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
school
let's go
[Music]
is
[Applause]
to pray with me as we close this
commencement
god of paradox
a noble in being
but known by experience
unlimited by dimensions
but present in time and space
unchanging
but moved by the sufferings of all
thank you for the preservation of life
in the midst of death
for community
in the wake of isolation
for the jubilation of an embodied
commencement
give these we celebrate
the daring to attempt what seems
impossible
capacity to perceive
what appears unknowable
the integrity to act on principle
where no moral compass is discernible
bless the families that have given these
celebrants their past
this university that has shaped their
present
and bless these celebrants who will
shape the future
for us all
amen
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
my
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
mars
[Music]
caleb
um
let's play
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
you
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you